so
thank you
it's fine it's fine as it is behind soft I
see the young people I believe
can you tell me hello is now
very well here you are and to the youth
sailing also first of all my dear
friends
congratulations to senegal for  the big
victory at the can this
hesitation
and thank you thank you very much for your
welcome
thank you very much for your testimonies
it was so interesting to
speak and to listen to you for the story
of your journeys all so different
you told me but animated  of the
same patience and the same passion
this passion that you were helped you
to overcome scales you
spoke to me of the failures that you saw but
also of the successes that you had
until the realization of your projects and
I  see that you are an aspiration a
source of inspiration incredible
impressive thank you very much for that I
know how
difficult another buyer's journey can be this is
also the case we  will have for example we
slam the door on you the year united end
it's music that goes we ca
n't get loans you told me
it's really difficult to
have access to loans we  I don't know who to
contact, you also told me,
but when you have talent, you, like you,
you can do it and know that Europe
is there to support you and
support African initiatives at
the local level.  national or
regional the europe team to launch a
major initiative
to support entrepreneurs with
4.6 billion euros to help
young africans realize their
dreams good dreams are what counts
they know you realize to found their
startup your  start up and of course to
create jobs in the sectors of the future
you told me about
innovation energy transition for example
how do you say recycling
right recycling there were some
very interesting projects with shots
of tones  the
ai shots  theirs are no longer the most blue
and of course digital
digital is still an
important theme here and especially
the rat wants to support young girls
whose entrepreneurial journey I have
seen many
very courageous it is  the subject of the
program that we have just signed the
commissioner here with the
active solidarity association girls have the
means to succeed as much as boys
it is not always easy that I know
I am in a good position to know this but
my message  to you and that in time
to all of you have confidence in your
abilities and you will succeed
follow the example of the douars told me that
I believe it is important for you so
thank you for having received me here c  was
so impressive I take a
lot with me back home and of
course we keep in touch to
build what you started here
thank you very much
[Applause]